es gibt bei uns im westen der westlichen
welt zwei neue bedrohungen der
meinungsfreiheit und damit demokratie
finde ich die oft unterschätzt werden
die eine nenne ich die identität
ideologie dann werde jetzt viel sagen
hey was ist das denn es ist ganz einfach
zu erklären
man teilt die menschheit in zwei hälften
auf der einen seite
sind die guten und auf der anderen seite
sind die bösen die guten sind die wie
diskriminiert werden also wegen ihres
geschlechts deswegen ihre hautfarbe
wegen ihrer sexualität und so weiter die
bösen sind die diskriminieren also
meiner reise geht er sexuelle und so
weiter der clou bei dieser sache ist
dass man nichts tun muss und zu
diskriminieren also man muss nicht
wirklich jemanden diskriminiert haben
man ist einfach dieser eigenschaft also
zum beispiel weiß zu sein ist man ein
diskriminierender oder ein rassist und
umgekehrt ist es genauso
sie können ein millionär in beverly
hills sein und sich und diskriminiert
sein weil sie eben schwachsinn als
weil das ist eine irgendwie ihre
ideologie finde ich aber sie hat sehr
viele anhänger gefunden in grünen bei
den linken und hat auch bei der spd und
sie hat auch in den vielen medienhäusern
stabile mehrheiten inzwischen erreicht
ich halte sie deswegen für gefährlich
weil sie absolut intolerant ist und wenn
man der auffassung ist wir sind die
guten die anderen sind die bösen ist das
ja auch irgendwie konsequent intolerant
zu sein
die ja und eine sache ist noch wichtig
die diese ideologie hat starke
ähnlichkeit mit zwei anderen totalitären
ideologien nämlich einerseits dem
nationalismus unser volk ist das beste
die anderen taugen nichts und auf der
anderen seite mit dem kommunismus und
dem marxismus
kapitalisten böse arbeiterklasse gut das
ist also ein sehr schlichtes weltbild
dass man also recyceln kann auf diese
art und weise die zweite wie ich finde
gefährliche haltung die es immer
häufiger gibt heißt
meine meinung ist
wissenschaft das ist auch irgendwie irre
und das gab es auch schon im marxismus
da hat sich auf seine wissenschaft
gehalten und es gibt die wissenschaft ja
auch eigentlich gar nicht die
wissenschaft ändert ihre meinung ständig
die wissenschaft von vor 30 jahren ist
nicht mehr viel wert also ein letztes
beispiel zu dieser sache wenn karl
lauterbach zum beispiel sagt der
virologe
dessen meinung ich gerne hören das ist
die stimme der wissenschaft posten heißt
da und der virologe dessen meinung ich
mich sogar eine höhere steuer heißt da
er ist zweiter klasse zweitklassig auf
den müssen wir nicht zu hören also das
ist auch eine art und weise freie
debatten zu verhindern und
einzuschränken indem man bedeutet ist
ja immer sehr hart
trifft ihr natürlich den punkt eines
wirklich beunruhigen phänomens ich habe
mit ihm überlegt dass das
glücklicherweise auf der anderen seite
des ozeans vor allem bei den vereinigten
staaten stattfindet und den unis da wird
ja fast schon das geht jetzt schon in
den klinischen wahnsinn hinein was dort
zum teil geleert wird aber dass breitet
sich hier auch aus es ist kein neues
phänomen
es ist eigentlich das klassische
früherer wie dem gesagt das klassische
gutmenschentum und das was das
eigentlich ist niemand ist dagegen gute
menschen niemand ist gegen das gute aber
der gutmensch der redet nur von guten
meint aber sich selbst und das ist hier
die perfide technik man benutzt
toleranz scheinbare wachsamkeit
empfindsamkeit um sich damit auf ein
moralisches podest zu stellen und uns
normalsterblichen ein schlechtes
gewissen ein zehn jahren ich sage immer
oder ich spüre dann immer wenn das
eintritt was sie gesagt haben dass ich
vom inquisitoren
umzingelt binnen von diesen
schießscharten augen die mit lauren der
einfalt versuchen wir die worte so im
mund umzudrehen fake news dass man mich
irgendwie auf dem grillrost der
politischen korrektheit spedieren kann
die sind ja vier weiße männer hier da
heißt das heißt wir müssen schon jetzt
auch in der logik extrem aufpassen was
wir sagen ist fast schon eine
diskriminierende sendung die wir dann ja
hier
ja aber vielleicht dürfen nur zu
gewissen themen war ja frau gar nicht
äußern aber scherz beiseite ich glaube
das was roger köppel sagt geht auch in
der richtige richtung ich glaube aber
trotzdem dass es noch eine entwicklung
zusätzlich gegeben hat also das ist
nicht immer schon so war sondern dass
wir auch sehen selbst befreit ist future
wird gecancelt wenn man plötzlich als
weißer oder als weiße die falsche
falsche frisur trägt also da kommt mir
glaube schon in bereiche die ganz neu
sind cancelled culture ist ja an sich
ein ausdruck von angst also sie haben
das glaube ich ganz gut auch beschrieben
der nationalismus der kommunismus sind
ja eigentlich angst ideologien man weiß
man ist schwach und man versucht es dann
über gewisse aussagen und gewisse andere
merkmale sich stark zu fühlen also da
ist vieles was glaube ich da
zusammenkommt ein punkt den ich machen
möchte ist und ich glaube diese kerschl
tänzelte hat sich schon in die politik
bei uns gezogen gibt beispielsweise ein
bundeskanzler der beim thema und sie
haben gerade angesprochen auch beim
thema corona doch sehr auf die
wissenschaft gehört hat aber wenn es
beispielsweise um ökonom geht da hat er
gerade vor kurzem bei anne will gesagt
nein also dass wir alles quatsch was da
berechnet wurde er hat auch als der
wissenschaftliche beirat vor ein paar
monaten der wissenschaftliche beirat des
wirtschaftsministers etwas zum thema
rente erreichen hat gesagt ja das sieht
alles ziemlich düster aus da hat er den
vorgeworfen diesen ökonom dass sie
falsch gerechnet hätten das machen
damals der finanzmister scholz einfach
so aus der menge das hat auch was mit
ken johnson kyra und brillenträger jahr
sind wir auf der sicheren seite weil wir
gehören auch zu einer opfergruppe wir
sind die opfergruppe der kurs sich aber
ihr hab ich habe hier die mehrheit
aktion nehmen wir noch mal die
wissenschaftler was ich reklamiere ist
dass man die nicht in einen raum
gesperrt und die mit seilen mit einer
konsolidierten meinung auskommt also ja
es mag extreme ansichten gehen der eine
forscht er so und der andere hat dem
blickwinkel aber ich würde mehrere
anhören irgendwie die mehrheit oder das
konsolidierte votum nehmen und den
privilegierten das kennen wir in der
start up welt gar nicht
migrationshintergrund diverse teams
älter jünger weiblich männlich
flüchtlingskinder dabei dass am bin ich
da regiert pragmatismus in der start up
szene gibt es das nicht das finde ich
einen ganz wesentlichen punkt den sie
jetzt gebraucht haben das ist nämlich
die außerkraftsetzung des
leistungsprinzips wenn man die
menschheit nun auch auf teilt nach
biologischen herkunfts kriterien des
biologismus eine ganz üble geschichte
und das gute an der marktwirtschaft ist
ja dass das leistungsprinzip geht das
heißt unabhängig woher ich komme welche
religion hautfarbe welche haarfarbe habe
ich kann ich mich aufgrund der leistung
die ich in den augen anderer erbringe in
einem völlig neuen gesellschaftlichen
status bringen und das mit gerückt
abgewickelt durch diese kanzlei war city
und was ist das da noch diese
minderheitenpolitik auffällig ist
natürlich dass man
die verhält ist einfach umdreht also bei
den rassisten klassischer werbung ist
natürlich hautfarbe und herkunft so das
ist das gewesen was man den leuten zum
fast weil was der rassistischen anderen
zum vorwurf macht und nun dreht man es
um und man
macht den weißen ihre hautfarbe und ihre
herkunft also fortschritt kann ich das
nicht erkennen
nur dass die rollen neu besetzt werden
aber man kann vielleicht sogar sagen
dass es sich darum ein eine konstante
der geschichte handelt denn die haltung
wir sind die guten die anderen sind die
bösen die hat es sehr wahrscheinlich
auch in der steinzeit schon gegeben also
wir kreisender um die steinzeit und
müssen erkennen dass
meinungsfreiheit und demokratie ihr
alles andere als der normal der
geschichte ist das ist eine winzig
kleine historische zone in einer hand
voll ländern die wirklich freien
meinungsaustausch kennen den
demokratische verhältnisse herrschen das
ist immer betont dass es immer an
minderheiten phänomen gewesen und
deswegen muss man halt ständig darum
kämpfen dass es so bleibt und jetzt ist
die große frage wird eigentlich
schlimmer mit den jahren mit der
zunehmenden nutzung beispielsweise von
social media wo man sich in echo kann
man nur noch anfällt also eigentlich das
ja so aussuchen kann dass man nur noch
mit lehm bestärkt wird was man auch
selbst hören möchte ansonsten blockiert
man einfach den einen oder anderen
nutzer ich glaube da gibt es eine
entwicklung dass erde und das ist anders
als jetzt von der startup-szene sich die
menschen dann genau diese echo kammer
suchen klar in freundeskreisen kann man
das auch machen aber da kann man nicht
einfach sagen jetzt roger köppel sind
sie einfach mal leise aber ich kann sie
abstellen wenn ich
nicht schon längst damit angefangen nur
noch meine eigenen artikel zu lesen dass
heute geht's mir besser meine eigene
echo treffen kommt gut aber sie holt
mich da immer wieder reißen das feld
also manchmal muss man sich vielleicht
auch vor diesen anonymen
heckenschützen schützen ich vergleiche
das immer früher waren das an der
autobahn raste die die klo wende eine
obszöne sprüche waren
und irgendwelche gepflegten
telefonnummern und alles mögliche in der
anonymität da die anderen über leidigen
oder zu diskreditieren oder
runter zu putzen das so leicht also da
meine ich dass die kommentare generell
immer mit einem identitätsnachweis gar
nicht dass man die adresse von der
person haben möchte aber dass dieses
anonyme beschmutzen nicht geben in
redaktion ich möchte keine namen nennen
aus rücksichtnahme habe ich manchmal
leute getroffen junge menschen die von
der universität kamen und in diesem
beruf gingen die waren echt
überrascht und geschockt dass es
menschen gibt die andere auffassungen
haben als sie das hatten sie also
erkennbar
nicht oder selten erlebt ja nicht in der
familie nicht nichts an der uni nicht in
ihrer peergroup ja wie man so sagt und
wenn sie dann jemandem gegenüber stehen
der sagt nur ich sehe das völlig aber in
einer isolierung blase ja und das ist
gute ihnen dann richtig weh das ist ganz
traurig er und wissen nicht was sie tun
sollen
beim thema rollenbilder auf jeden fall
ein wenig und gehen weiter zurück köpfe
der über ein vorfall berichtet bei den
oscars den sie vielleicht sogar auch
schon gewalt haben